here with more reaction senate judiciary
committee chairman
lindsey graham now i'll be honest
every possible not one senator had to be
in the room
you made teleconferencing zooming face
timing whatever you want to call it
available to everybody
i understand that antivirals were
cleaned out the entire room ahead of
time
i saw a distancing of
what 12 feet between every senator
people had the option as i understand it
to get more tests if they felt the need
to do so
mike lee was cleared by his doctor to be
there but yet they tried to attack
you on that issue your reaction
was probably the safest room in america
to be in we took a lot of care to make
sure it was cdc compliant
millions of americans went to work today
and restaurants and factories
military members reported for duty
police and firemen
when you have a positive in the unit you
don't shut the unit down you deal with
it responsibly
i don't need to be tested i was negative
a week ago friday i have
no reason under the guidelines to be
tested it was a safe place
to conduct a hearing but it was
important and let me tell you what i got
out of this
nobody's really mentioned this today
when joni ernst
and marshall blackburn spoke in their 10
minutes
you could see the emotion coming from
their soul
why is this so important donald trump
nominated
someone to the court the fifth woman in
the history of our nation
who is unashamedly pro-life and
conservative
we have to win this for all the young
women out there
who are conservative to show them
there's a place at the table for you
finally women go through hell who
embrace conservatism
who dare to be pro-life in a liberal
medias
senator eyes tim scott goes through hell
senator if i remember correctly um
and i didn't agree with you at the time
uh
didn't you vote for liberal justices on
the supreme court what were their names
elena kagan i believe
and sonia sotomayor correct yeah
and you knew their judicial philosophy
from yours
sure yeah so uh justice scalia got 98
votes
and justice ginsburg got 96 votes it
used not to be this way
it's uh is thomas is bork
alito and kavanaugh if we had backed out
on kavanaugh
who would step forward in the
conservative world if we can get this
wonderfully qualified conservative woman
on the court we'll be making a statement
to all young conservative women there's
a place at the table for you
this may be the most important thing i
ever do in the united states senate is
to make sure this
fine nominee who happens to be a
conservative woman
makes it through the process i promise
everybody who's listening i will do my
best
let me ask you this they are trying to
scare the american people that
they know that amy coney barrett will
get rid of
obamacare which by the way none of the
promises were kept right and that roe v
wade which by the way if it ever was
overturned which i don't really think it
will
and by the way even amy coney barrett
has said that
all abortion would be legal no it would
be sent back to the states
my question to you is has any judicial
nominee for the supreme court
has any of them ever telegraphed how
they would vote
on any topic or is there something
called the ruth bader ginsburg answer
well the ginsburg rule is that you're
not supposed to tip your hand or tell
somebody how you may rule an ongoing
litigation
as justice ginsburg said a couple years
ago a president is elected for four
years not three
uh the ginsburg rule is alive and well
you cannot ask her to tell
tell us in the committee how she would
rule on a particular case you can't
bargain
with the judge if you'll tell me how
you're going to
vote i'll vote for you here's what's
important 360 million dollars have been
raised since the passing of
justice ginsburg by democrats i am
worried about tomorrow
and uh wednesday i'm afraid that the
democratic base
is going to push these senators to
declare war on this nominee
my opponent raised 57 million dollars
one of the reasons he's raising so much
money
is i stood up for kavanaugh they tried
to take kavanaugh out
i'm worried about amy barrett she can
handle what comes her way but argent
our republicans need to defend her and
we will so help me at lindsey graham.com
they're trying to silence us all by
swamping us with money
so this is a fight that really does
matter
you nearly have a hundred million
dollars thrown at you by the likes of
rosie o'donnell
barbara streisand every i think rob
reiner if i'm not mistaken
uh i hope the people of south carolina
don't allow barbara streisand and rosie
to decide you're a race or the president
or the race for president thank you sir
for being with us